Jean-Baptiste a quitté Paris le
marketing et l'architecture pour les
fleurs et le Berry ce premier printemps
est un succès il est arrivé au bon
moment les producteurs en Hollande ou au
Kenya ou en Afrique centrale utilise
beaucoup de produits phytosanitaires qui
sont de plus en plus coûteux le
transport est de plus en plus coûteux
donc aujourd'hui sur une exploitation
classique en fait on peut tout à fait de
compétitif par rapport à la fleur
d'import qui représente aujourd'hui 85%
de la fleur qu'on trouve chez les
fleuristes les mentalités changent les
clients veulent consommer local c'est
mieux pour la planète et pour l'emploi
Floriane était fleuriste elle vient
d'être embauchée c'est important de
prendre soin de la terre prendre soin de
l'environnement et je pense que c'est la
responsabilité de tous presque toutes
les fleurs arrivent ici en graines
Jean-Baptiste surveille ses semis caché
en train de regarder les amarantes
et on a ses couvercles là parce que pour
que l'amarante elle germe il faut
qu'elle voit le soleil donc la graine
est juste posée sur le terreau en
surface et j'arrose par le dessous pour
la première année 45 000 fleurs ont été
où seront semés 300 variétés au total
des câlins
les dernières tulipes des fleurs de
saison à la saison c'est le moment des
renoncules et des animaux il n'y aura
pas de rose en hiver c'est un choix je
voulais absolument cultiver la fleur de
A à Z parce que c'est de là que je tire
la fierté de mon travail Jean-Baptiste
fournit déjà une quinzaine de
professionnels de la région et des
particuliers pour les fleuristes ça part
ça part dans des colis par transporteur
ils sont livrés dans les 12 heures en
fait donc je livre dans la dans la
région un livre dans l'Inde
l'Indre-et-Loire le Cher
et le Loir-et-Cher pour le moment et le
samedi et quelques fois en semaine je
fais des marchés donc le samedi je suis
obligatoirement à Châteauroux seul
grossiste de l'Indre il fait partie du
collectif de la fleur française des
professionnels qui ont décidé de se
battre pour reconstruire toute une
filière les fleuristes s'engagent à
proposer 50% de fleurs locales et s'il
n'y a pas de rose en hiver est-ce
vraiment un problème